[Music]
imagine you're standing at one end of a
large room and your friend is at the
other end you whisper something barely
audible to the person standing next to
you but your friend can clearly hear
what you said how amazing this would be
right is this possible
what do you think well this magical
thing is possible if the ceiling of the
room is spherically shaped like an
ellipse this shape which looks like a
stretched circle is what makes the
whispering magic possible if the ceiling
of the room is elliptical in shape
technically semi elliptical here then
there are two special points in the room
where you and your friend can stand if
one of you whispers something then all
the sound waves gets reflected from the
elliptical ceiling towards the other
person so as the sound waves from one
point gets reflected and focused onto
the other point your friend can hear
your whisper this works the other way
around as well if your friend whispers
something you will be able to hear
clearly as well based on this reflective
property of ellipse many rooms called
whispering galleries have been
constructed for example there's one at
the Grand Central Terminal in New York
City isn't this shape interesting each
of these two special points of the
ellipse is referred to as focus and
together they're called the foci of the
ellipse wait there's more
elliptical shapes even play a role in a
medical device called a little trip tur
due to its reflective property it's used
to break the kidney stones high
frequency shock waves are generated at
one focus of the elliptical shaped
reflector which gets concentrated at
another focus point where the kidney
stones are positioned and this helps in
breaking the kidney stones there is so
much more that can be done with an
elliptical shape can you explore other
applications of the shape and tell us in
the comments
below in the next part let's understand
what exactly an ellipse is how do we
understand the shape of an ellipse
suppose we have two points in a play we
name this point as f1 and this point as
f2 now consider a special set of points
on the same plane they are placed such
that their sum of the distances from
these two points is constant let me
explain suppose we take a point here
let's name it a now let's say the sum of
its distances from point F 1 and point F
2 is some number alpha now consider all
such points whose sum of the distance
from these two points is exactly equal
to alpha are there any such points yes
there are many more collection of all
such points is called an ellipse let's
say we take a point B on the ellipse
then the sum of its distances from the
points F 1 and F 2 will be alpha let's
take another point C here again the sum
of its distance from these two points
will be alpha so we see that the ellipse
is a collection of all points in a plane
such that their sum of distances from
the two fixed points in the plane is
constant each fixed point F 1 and F 2 is
called the focus of the ellipse and
together they call the force I of the
ellipse
here we took the constant to be alpha
but we can take it any number for the
constant sum of distances with the only
condition being that it should be
greater than the distance between the
four side of the ellipse
now suppose we want the constant sum of
distances to be beta let's say beta is
greater than alpha then the set of
points corresponding to this constant
beta will beat this ellipse if we take
the constant to be the number of gamma
which is less than alpha then the
ellipse will look like this
now let's look at one ellipse an
interesting thing happens when the two
foci of the ellipse coincide can you
guess
we get a circle all the points will be
at a distance of alpha over two from the
center where the two foci coincide so we
see that a circle is a special case of
an ellipse when the two foci of ellipse
coincide so now we know that for an
ellipse we need to know two things first
is the two fixed points called the force
I of the ellipse and second the constant
sum of the distances of the points on
the ellipse from these force I then the
ellipse is the collection of all the
points whose sum of the distances from
the force I is that constant now many of
you may have a question from our example
of the Whispering Gallery suppose you
and your friends are in a Whispering
Gallery with an elliptical shape ceiling
how will you know where to stand to hear
the whispers of each other
that is where the four sigh of the
elliptical ceiling are for this we need
to delve a little deeper into
understanding this shape we will look at
this in the next lesson there we will
understand some terminologies associated
with the ellipse do you subscribe to our
channel to stay updated
[Music]